Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David P, I would love to hear from you if
you have any message for me, hopefully a polite
one of you can leave it at two one nine two.
David P. Here's a great question about something
we've touched on a little bit before, but
it's particularly relevant now in the conversations
about the January 6th riots.
Why are some in the media referring to these
right wing terrorists as militia members?
Take a listen.
Speaker 5: Yes, I was just wondering why the
media continues to call these right wing terrorist
groups militia.
They are actually vigilantes, right?
Media people are really always very critical
about how they use words, vigilantes or people
who take the law into their own hands.
And that's what they are.
They're not militia and they want to sell.
They want to call themselves militia just
to some more legitimate.
Speaker 1: Of course, this has been something
we've talked about for a long time.
And many of these groups, these sovereign
citizen groups and these anti-government groups
and those who those who come out to oppose
antifa, sometimes with violence or whatever
the case may be.
And by the way, that's not me endorsing violence
from anybody to be to be very clear, they
want to be called militia.
Militia sounds sort of like an unofficial
military battalion or platoon or whatever
the case may be.
You're talking about vigilantes who are taking
the law into their own hands in in violation
of the law.
You're talking in many cases when they actually
go out and commit acts of whatever.
We're talking about terrorism here.
And I think the media, corporate media would
be much more accurate if they were using that
term rather than militia at minimum, say,
self-described militia, which is not actually
a real thing in terms of legally binding or
conferring any kind of rights or privileges
to be vigilantes.
This is something that they've dubbed themselves.
It's extrajudicial.
It's not recognized by the law in any way,
shape or form.
It would be great if that was made more clear
on a regular basis, very astutely pointing
that out in the voice mail call if you have
a message for me, two one nine two David P
on the bonus show today, the Colonial Pipeline
CEO now admits to authorizing a greater than
four million dollar ransom where payment to
get the pipeline flowing again.
Incredible.
Chicago Mayor Lightfoot says she will only
be giving one on one interviews to journalists
of color.
We will weigh in on that.
And the governor of Texas, Greg Abbott, has
now signed into law one of the most restrictive
abortion bills in the country, which would
ban abortion as early as six weeks.
We will talk about whether that will hold
legally and much, much more on today's bonus
show.
Please get access to the bonus show.
This is my please clap moment.
Please get access.
Sign up at David Pakman Dotcom, make a pledge
at Patreon Dotcom Slash The David Pakman Show
and then you will be brought right into the
world of the award winning world famous bonus
show.
I will be joined by producer Pat and I will
see you that.